[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Good
morning, everyone.
Welcome to the 13th
lecture of 6.006.
Just to recap from
last time, we've
been talking about shortest--
single source shortest
paths on weighted graphs
for the past two lectures.
Previously we were only talking
about unweighted graphs.
And so far, up until today,
we've talked about three ways
to solve single source shortest
paths on weighted graphs.
Namely the first one used BFS.
If you can kind of
transform your graph
into a linear-sized graph that's
unweighted that corresponds
to your weighted
problem, essentially
replacing each weighted
edge with of weight
w with w single edges.
Now that's only good for
positive weight things
and if the sum of your
weights are small.
But if the sum of
your weights is
linear in the combinatorial
size of your graph,
V plus E, then we can get
a linear time algorithm
to solve weighted shortest paths
using breadth-first search.
Then we talked
about how we could--
if we-- the problem with
weighted shortest paths
is if our weights were negative
and there could exist cycles,
then we could have
negative weight cycles
and that would be more
difficult to handle,
because then you have
vertices where you have
an unbounded number
of edges you might
have to go through
for a shortest path.
There might not be a finite
length shortest path.
But in the condition
where we didn't
have cycles in the graph--
of course, we couldn't
have negative weight ones,
so we were also able to
do that in linear time
by exploiting the fact
that our vertices could
be ordered in a
topological order,
and then we could kind of
push shortest path information
from the furthest one
back to the ones forward.
By relaxing edges forward.
By maintaining this invariant
that we had shortest paths as
we were processing these
things in topological order.
Then last time, we were talking
about general graphs, graphs
that could contain cycles,
and this is our most general
algorithm, because if there
are negative weight cycles,
Bellman-Ford, which we
talked about last time,
can detect them.
And in particular,
for any vertex
that had a finite
weight shortest paths--
path, we could compute
that shortest path for it,
compute its distance.
And for any one
that is reachable
from a negative weight
cycle, not only could we
mark it as minus
infinity distance,
but we could also find
a negative weight cycle
essentially by duplicating
our graph to make it a DAG
and being able to follow
pointers back in this expanded
DAG that had multiple layers.
So that's what we've
done up until now.
We've gotten linear for
some types of graphs.
And we've gotten kind
of quadratic V times
E for general graphs, ones that
could contain negative cycles.
Now how bad is this?
Well, if the graph is sparse,
if the number of edges
in our graph is
on the order of V,
then this is quadratic
time and V, V squared.
But if the graph is dense
where we have quadratic--
like the complete graph
where every edge is present,
then we have quadratically
many edges in our graph in V.
And so this running
time is V cubed.
V cube's not great in
terms of its running time.
We would like something
closer to linear.
And so that's what
we're going to do today.
If we have this
restriction where
we have non-negative
weights, we can
have negative weight cycles.
And this is a restriction that
comes up a lot for many graphs
you might encounter.
A lot of times you don't have
both positive and negative
weight.
I don't have a negative
distance to my house.
In any metric we have
non-negative weights.
So these things come up a
lot, and we can actually
do quite a bit better, since
there are no negative weight
cycles, we can
get almost linear.
It's not going to be quite
V plus E as you see up here
on the slide.
We're going to get
something very close.
It's V plus the E,
but on the V term,
we have this
logarithmic factor in V.
Which remember for all
intents and purposes,
this log of that
thing in real life
is not going to be bigger
than like a factor of 30
or something like that.
Maybe 60.
But it's a small number.
And so this is actually
pretty good performance.
It's almost linear-- that's what
I'm saying almost linear here,
and that's what we're
going to try to do today.
So, how do we do this?
Well, I'm going to make two
observations here, first off.
Our idea is going to be to
generalize the notion of BFS.
When we had BFS, we
split up our graph--
to solve unweighted-- solve
weighted shortest paths in BFS,
we could take our
positive edge weights,
break them up into
individual edges.
But if the total weight
of our edges was large,
then we'd have a problem,
because now we've
expanded the size of our graph.
This is the same issue that we
had with something like radix
sort where we don't
want our algorithm
to run in the size of
the numbers in our input,
we want our algorithm to
run in the number of numbers
in our input.
This is the difference
between N and U
back when we were talking
about data structures.
Here, if the size of our weights
are large compared to V and E,
then doing this expansion
is going to be difficult.
But if we had, say, some graph--
this is my graph G, and
we had a source vertex
s, the idea here
is going to still
be to try to grow a
frontier of increasing
distance from my source and try
to maintain all of the things
within a certain
distance from my source.
So that's the idea, grow a
sphere centered at my source,
repeatedly explore
closer vertices
before I get to further ones.
But how can I explore
closer vertices
if I don't know the
distances beforehand?
This is kind of-- seems
like a circular logic.
I'm going to use the
distance to my things
to compute the
distances to my things.
That doesn't work so well.
So how do we do this?
Well, the idea here is
to gradually compute
the distances-- compute
the distances as we go so
that we maintain this property.
Now this property, this idea
wouldn't work necessarily
in the context of
negative edge weights.
Here, we have this
growing frontier,
this ball around my source.
And as I grow my
thing, these things are
at further and further distance,
because any edge from something
back here as I'm growing
my ball a certain distance,
these things are
outside that distance.
We're kind of using a
key observation here.
Here's my observation 1.
If weights greater
than or equal to 0,
then distances increase
along shortest paths.
Maybe weakly
monotonically increase
if there are zero-weight edges.
But in general, if I had a
path going from s to some v,
and it's going
through some vertex u,
I have some shortest path.
This is the shortest
path from s to v,
and it goes through some
point u, some vertex u.
Then this monotonicity more
specifically means that
the shortest path from s to u
and the shortest path from s
to v, which is this
whole thing, how
do these relate to each other?
If this is along
that path, then this
has to be at least as
large as the subpath.
Because all of these--
the weight of this path
cannot be negative.
So that's the thing that
Dijkstra's going to exploit.
It essentially
means that when I'm
expanding this frontier
of distance away from x,
it's possible if I had negative
weight, that this line--
if I had some very negative
weight going from a vertex
here to a vertex
here, this vertex
could be within this boundary.
Maybe if this distance is x,
this guy could be within x.
The things that are
within distance x of s
might not be all contained.
There could be a path from
here to this other vertex width
distance x.
It doesn't have this property
because I could decrease
in distance along the path.
So that's the first observation.
Second observation,
well, let's see
if we can piggyback
on DAG relaxation.
I claim to you that we can solve
single source shortest paths
faster if we're given
an order of vertices
in increasing
distance beforehand.
Distance from s.
So here's the idea.
I'm not going to give
you the distances
to all these vertices.
Instead I'm going to
give you the order
of the vertices in some
increasing distance from s.
So basically I'm saying, if
I had some, I don't know,
here's a graph.
Let's see if I can remember.
OK, and I'm going to
put some edges on here.
OK.
And I'm going to call these
vertices 0, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
OK.
So here's a graph.
Maybe I put some
edge weights on here.
I'm going to say this one is 3,
this one is 2, this one is 3,
this is 1, this is 1,
this is 0, and this is 0.
So from vertex 1 to
2, that was the 2
for the labeling of that vertex.
That edge is zero-weight.
OK.
So here's a weighted graph
And I don't necessarily know--
I could use Bellman-Ford to find
shortest paths from this vertex
0, but the idea here is
I'm not going to give you
shortest paths, I'm going to
try to compute shortest paths,
but I'm going to give you
some additional information.
I'm going to give you the order
of their shortest path distance
from the source.
And I can just--
I'm going to eyeball
this and say--
I'm going to change
this slightly
to make it a little
bit more interesting.
I'm going to say
this is distance 4.
OK.
All right, so now what we have
is the shortest path distance--
I'm just eyeballing this.
The shortest distance to--
bad example.
All right.
So, these are the weights.
Shortest-path distance
to 3 is going to be 2,
I'm going to say, through there.
Shortest-path distance
here is 2 also.
here is also 2
because I can go through both
of these 0's and it's not
a problem.
And then the
shortest-path distance
here is 2 to here
and a 1/3 to there.
So these are listed
in increasing distance
from my source.
I had to compute those
deltas to convince you
that this was the
right ordering,
but this is a right
ordering of these things.
Now it's not the
only right ordering,
but it is a right ordering.
OK, so I'm told--
I'm arguing to you that I could
solve a single source shortest
paths in linear time
if I were to give you
the vertices in
increasing distance?
How could I do that?
Well, because of this
first observation,
I know that if these are
increasing in distance,
any edge going backwards
with respect to this ordering
can't participate in shortest
paths with one exception.
Anyone know what
that exception is?
No edge can go backwards
in this ordering
based on this observation
except under what condition?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If the weight is 0?
JASON KU: If the
weight to 0, yeah.
So if the weight to 0, just
like this situation here,
then I could go backwards
in the ordering.
See, it's problematic.
The idea is I'm going to
want to construct a DAG
so that I can run
DAG relaxation.
Well, if I have a component
here that has 0 weights,
I can coalesce this thing down--
I can deal with this
component separately.
Let's worry about
that separately.
If we do, we can collapse this
edge down into a single vertex
and transform this graph so
it does respect the ordering.
So I'm going to transform
this graph into a new graph.
This is a graph--
contains vertex 2 and vertex
0, vertex 1 and 3 here,
and vertex 4.
OK, now we have--
and I'm only going to keep
edges going forward in the--
I'm going to need to collapse
this entire section down
into one vertex.
This doesn't quite work.
OK.
Let's ignore zero-weight
edges for now.
Let's assume these are--
all right, there's
something broken here.
If I have a cycle here--
right now I don't have
a cycle of zero-weight.
So what I could do is I
could take this vertex
and put it after both
of these vertices.
And now I would--
or I could rearrange the
order of these three vertices
where there's a path of length
0 and get a new ordering that
still satisfies the property.
And that's always the case
because paths can't increase--
paths can't decrease in weight.
I can rearrange the
ordering of these things
so that 3 comes
first, 1 comes second,
and 2 comes third of
those three vertices.
Yeah.
So for every set of 0 edges, I
can just flip the relationship
if they have the same distance.
In my input, I'm given vertices
that have the same distance
from the source.
And so if those are the same
distance from the source
and they're connected
by a zero-weight edge,
it doesn't hurt me to
flip their ordering.
So I'm going to do that.
So let's convert
that into a graph
with a different ordering.
0 3 now, 1 2.
OK and I have this distance,
this edge, this edge,
this edge, this edge.
This edge.
What am I missing?
2 to 3.
And here.
I think I have all
of those edges.
Yeah?
OK.
Now I have the property
that every edge that
could participate
in the shortest path
are going forward in the
ordering, because all of these
are zero-weight.
So we flip those
around so they're
going correct with
respect to the ordering.
And any edge going
backwards that
is positive weight
certainly can't
be used in any shortest path.
So I'm just going
to get rid of them.
Yeah?
What do I do if there's
a zero-weight cycle?
JASON KU: If there's
a zero-weight cycle,
I can just coalesce
them all together down
to a single vertex, because
if I reach one of them,
I can reach all of them.
AUDIENCE: You're getting a
topological ordering of--
JASON KU: Exactly.
I'm computing-- so
the idea here is we're
trying to construct a DAG.
I can construct this
DAG in linear time.
And then I can
run DAG relaxation
on this graph in linear
time to get shortest paths.
So that's an approach.
If I knew the ordering
of the vertices
in increasing distance, then
I could use DAG relaxation.
So we're going to use both
of these observations.
That's how we're going to solve
this single source shortage
problem with non-negative
weights using Dijkstra.
So that's finally now
where we're coming to.
Sorry, I missed a case here
when I was writing up my notes,
and I tried to fix it live and
hopefully you guys followed me.
OK.
Dijkstra's algorithm.
Did I spell that right?
Kind of.
OK.
What?
Dijkstra.
OK.
Now Dijkstra was this
Dutch computer scientist.
This is him.
Pretty famous, he
wrote a monograph
on why programming
languages should
start with 0 indexing as opposed
to 1 indexing, so I like him.
But in particular, he designed
this very nice generalization
of BFS for weighted graphs.
But maybe I didn't
spell this right
because when he writes
his name, he writes it
with a Y with a dash over it.
So in reality on a
Dutch typewriter,
you might have a character
that looks like this, Y
with a umlaut on top of it.
But on modern-- on
an English keyboard,
this looks pretty
similar to an IJ.
So in a lot of manuscripts,
we write it as D-I--
there's no J sound in Dijkstra.
It's coming from this is Y here.
That's an interesting way to
remember how to spell Dijkstra.
But the basic idea behind
Dijkstra is the following idea.
Relaxed edges from vertices
in increasing distance
from source.
OK.
This is the same
kind of difficulty
we had before when we were
trying to generalize BFS.
So how do we know what
the next vertex is
with increasing distance to s?
Well, the second idea is find
the next vertex efficiently
using a data structure.
And the data structure
we're going to use
is something I like to call
a changeable priority queue.
So this is a little different
than a normal priority queue
that we had at the end of
our data structures unit.
This changeable priority
queue has three operations.
We're going to say it's a queue.
We can build it on an
iterable set of items.
Just stick x-- like
n items in there.
We can delete min
from the queue.
OK, this is the same now
as the priority queue.
It's this third operation
that's going to be different.
Decrease the key of an
item that has id, id.
OK, so this is a little strange.
What the heck is this id?
All right, with a change
of priority queue,
each of our items has two
values instead of one value.
It has a key, but it also--
on which the priority queue
is leading the min item
with the minimum key.
But also, each item
has an ID associated
with it, a unique integer.
So that when we
perform this operation,
decrease_key, it can find some
item in our data structure
with the given ID.
And if it's
contained there, it's
going to change its key
to some smaller value k.
And don't worry about
the edge cases here.
We're always going to
make sure this k is
going to be smaller
then whatever
that key was to begin with.
So this is really a kind
of a funky operation.
If I had a priority queue, not
a changeable priority queue,
but I had a priority
queue and I wanted
to implement a change
of priority queue,
how could I do it?
Well, a regular priority
queue is already
going to get me
these two operations.
It's just this one.
I essentially need to
find something by an ID
and then update its key.
So the idea how
to implement this
is going to be to use a
regular priority queue.
I'm going to call it Q prime.
And I'm going to cross-link
it with a dictionary D.
So these are just regular
priority queue on my items
that has the key
as defined above.
But I'm going to cross-link it
with a dictionary, a dictionary
that maps IDs to their
location in the priority queue.
We've done this many times in
the data structures section.
We're trying to cross
link to data structures
to make a query on a
different type of key
to find its place in
another data structure.
So, if we had a
priority a dictionary,
we could do this
stuff pretty fast.
In particular, I'm
going to assume
that our IDs of our vertices
are the integers between 0
and v minus 1.
And so for my dictionary,
I could get constant time
looking up of that ID by
using what data structure?
AUDIENCE: Hash table.
JASON KU: We could get--
OK, so we could get
expected constant time
if we used a hash table.
But if we knew that
our vertex IDs were
just the numbers
from 0 to v minus 1,
we could get rid of
that expected time
by using a direct access array.
Great.
OK, so that's the assumption.
And so really, the
name of the game
here is to choose a
priority queue here
that's going to make
these things fast when we
start to look at Dijkstra.
OK, so we're going to
use this data structure
to keep track of our
distance estimates
to all of the
vertices away from s.
OK, so this is
Dijkstra's algorithm.
OK.
Set-- so same
initialization step.
We're going to set--
this is a distance
estimate d, not delta.
We're going to want
the d's be our delta
is at the end of the algorithm.
That's what we're
going to have to prove.
So we first set all of them to
infinity, and then set d of s,
s equal to 0.
And here, we're never
going to update it again,
because our shortest
distance is in a graph
with non-negative edge weights
certainly can't go below 0.
All right.
Now we build our--
build our changeable
priority queue--
queue-- with an item--
I'm going to say an item is--
x is represented by
a tuple of its ID,
and then its key just
for brevity here.
With an item v, d of s, v.
So I'm going to be storing in
my changeable priority queue
the vertex label and its
shortest-path distance estimate
d.
And that's going to be the
key, the minimum that I'm
trying going to be querying
on for each the v and V.
So I'm going to
build that thing.
It's going to then have all
of my vertices in my graph.
Then while my changeable
priority queue still
has items, not empty, I'm
going to delete some u, d s, u.
So some item such
that its distance
is minimized from Q that
has minimum distance.
OK.
So I'm going to
I'm going to look
at all the things in
my priority queue.
At the start it's
just going to be s,
because everything as
shortest-path distance
estimate infinite except for s.
And so that's
clearly the smallest.
OK, so I'm going to
remove that from my queue,
and then I'm going
to process it.
How am I going to process it?
It's the exact same kind
of thing as DAG relaxation.
I'm going to relax all
its outgoing edges.
So just for completeness for
v in the outgoing adjacencies
of u, I'm going to relax--
sorry.
We have to check
whether we can relax it.
Basically if the shortest-path
distance estimate to v
is greater than going to u first
and then crossing that edge,
if going through
that is better, this
is violating our
triangle inequality.
And so we relax edge u, v, and
by that we mean set this thing
to be equal to that thing.
That's what we meant by relax.
And then we have one
other thing to do.
We have changed these
distance estimates
but our Q doesn't know that
we change these things.
We added these items in here.
But it doesn't know that
my distances have changed.
So we to tell the Q to remember
to change its key value
associated with the item v.
So decrease-- what is it?
Decrease key vertex
v in Q to the new d
s, v, the one that I
just decreased here.
And I know that I decreased
it because I said it
to a smaller value.
That makes sense.
All right, so that's Dijkstra.
Let's run it on an example.
So here's an example.
I have a directed graph.
It does contain cycles.
In particular, here
are some cycles.
I think those are the main ones.
There are definitely
cycles in this graph.
But as you see,
all of the weights
are non-negative, in
particular-- they're positive,
actually.
It's going to be just helpful
in writing out this example.
So let's run Dijkstra
on this graph.
First we initialize and we set
the shortest-path distance.
I'm going to label it in white
here to all of the things.
Then I'm going to,
as I update it,
I'm just going to cross them
out and write a new number.
So that's what it
is at the start.
That's initialization,
that's after step 1.
And then I stick things
into my Q. What's in my Q?
Here's my Q. It's everything.
It's vertices s, a, b, c, d.
I got five items
in my Q. Really,
it's the item pair with its
shortest distance estimate,
I'm just not going
to rewrite that here.
So the idea here is--
the while loop, OK.
Q is not empty, great.
We're going to delete the one
with the smallest distance
estimate, which
is s, right, yeah.
So I remove that, and then
I relax edges out of s.
So I relax edge here to a.
That's better than the
distance estimate--
10 is better than the
distance estimate infinite,
so I'm going to
change this to 10.
And then here's
another outgoing edge.
3 is better than
infinite, so I'm
going to change its delta to 3.
OK.
So now I go back in here and I
change the distance estimates
associated with my Q.
Now, next step of the
algorithm, s is done.
I've processed everything
distance 0 away.
But I'm now going to
use my priority queue
to say which of my vertices
has the shortest distance
estimate now.
So which one is it?
a, b, or c, or d?
Yeah, it's 3 and c.
3 is smaller than 10.
So Q is going to
magically delete c for me,
tell me what that is, and now
I'm going to process that.
Now I've changed my
boundary to this.
And now I relax edges out of c.
So here's an edge
at a c, that's a 4.
A 4 plus the 3 is smaller
than 10, so I update it.
3 plus 8 is 11, that's smaller
than infinite, so I update it,
I relax.
3 plus 2 is smaller
than infinite,
so I relax that as well.
Now of the things
still left in my Q,
I'm actually going to
remove it from my Q
instead of crossing it
out, maybe that's better.
Of the vertices still left in my
Q, which has smallest distance?
Yeah.
d.
d has 5, 7, or 11.
5 is the smallest.
So I remove d from my cue
and I relax edges from it.
And now my boundary looks
something like this.
I relax edges out of it.
5 plus 5, that's 10.
10 is smaller than
11, so that's a 10.
And that's the only
outgoing edge from d.
so I'm done.
And then the last, 7
is smaller than 10,
I relax edges out of a.
a to b, 7 plus 2
is smaller than 10.
And now I'm done.
So what I did every
time I removed s--
or I removed a vertex, I said
its shortest-path distance
to the small--
the last value I assigned to it.
So this was then 3, and
then a was 7, b was 9,
and then d was 5.
So that's Dijkstra in action.
It seems like these are the
shortest-path distances,
but how do we prove that?
Did it do the right thing?
Well, let's find out.
So that's what we're going to
spend some time on right now,
just talking about the
correctness of Dijkstra's
algorithm.
OK.
Correctness follows from
two main observations.
So the claim here that we're
trying to prove is that d of s
equals the delta s--
so the estimates equal
the shortest-path distance is
at the end of Dijkstra for all v
and V at end.
And this is going to follow
from two observations.
So the proof here,
first, if ever relaxation
sets d of s of v--
it sets the estimate equal to
the shortest-path distance,
if it ever does that, I argue
to you that still true at end.
OK, that's not a very
strong statement.
This is saying if I ever
set the distance estimate
to the true distance,
I'm never going to set it
to a different value later on.
And why is that?
Well, relaxation only ever
decreases the distance.
Relaxation only
decreases d s, v.
But we proved in lecture
11-- so two lectures ago
that relaxation is safe.
And what does safe mean?
Safe means that relaxation--
that relaxation will only ever
change these distant estimates
to be either infinite--
it was never-- there was
never a path to my vertex.
Or it was the length of some
path to v. Length of some path.
OK.
So what does that mean?
It only decreases,
but it's always
the length of some
path to v. So if this
is the length of
the shortest path
to v, I could never set
it to a smaller length,
because there are no paths
with shorter distance.
That's the whole point.
OK.
So with this
observation, I'm going
to argue this final claim.
It suffices to show that my
estimate equals the shortest
distance when v is
removed from the Q.
And since I removed every vertex
from the Q in this while loop,
I will eventually said to
all of the distance estimates
to the real distance
and we'll be golden.
Happy days.
All right.
So we'll be done if we
can prove that statement.
All right.
So we're going to prove
this by induction obviously.
Induction on first k
vertices removed from the Q.
So the Q, we're popping vertices
from this Q in some order.
So I'm going to just
argue that this claim is
true for the first k.
Clearly that's true
for k equals 1.
Base case, k equals 1.
What is k equals 1?
That means the first
word vertex that I
pop has this property,
which is definitely true,
because we set the shortest
distance to s to be 0.
That's all good.
Now we have our inductive step.
Assume it's true for k prime--
sorry, k less than k prime.
And let's let v prime be
k prime vertex popped.
v prime.
OK.
And now let's look at
some shortest path from s
to v prime.
So we got the shortest
path from s to v prime.
It exists.
v prime is accessible.
Let's say we pruned
our graph to be
only the things
accessible from s
so that, yeah, there exists
the shortest path to v prime.
And now let's think
about these vertices.
Some of them were removed
from the Q and some of them
were not.
s was definitely
removed from the Q.
But some of these other
vertices might not be.
I want to be able to
induct on this path,
in particular, the
vertex before me
so that I can say
that when I removed
it and I relax the edge to v
prime, then we're all golden.
But that might not be the case.
There could be a vertex,
the vertex preceding me
in the graph in this
shortest path that was not
popped from Q. I need
to argue that it was
or some other thing.
So let's consider the first
vertex in this path from s
to v. I'm going to
call it y, I think.
Yeah.
A vertex y that is
not in Q. After I
pop v prime, this is the
first-- or before I pop v prime,
y is not in the Q. Now these
might be the same vertex
if all of the preceding ones
on this path were in the Q.
But in particular, we're
going to look at this guy.
And say its predecessor's
x in the path.
Well what do I know?
I know that x is in the queue.
Everything here was
popped from the Q--
not in.
Which means that by induction,
the shortest-path distance
was set here correctly.
So that the distance
estimate at y
can't be bigger than the
shortest path to x plus w x, y.
But this is on the
shortest path to y,
because the subpaths of shortest
paths or shortest paths.
So this has to equal d
s, y, the distance to y.
So actually, y is all good here.
And so if v prime
were y, we'd be done.
That's the same argument
is DAG relaxation.
But we need to prove
something about v prime.
Well, because we have
non-negative weights,
the distance to v prime
has to be at least as big
as this distance,
because it's a subpath.
So this has to be less than
or equal to the true distance
to v prime.
Because of negative--
non-negative weights,
because the weights
are non-negative.
But because
relaxation is safe, we
know that our distance
estimate for v prime
has to be at least the
shortest-path distance.
This is because it's safe.
This is-- weights are
greater than or equal to 0.
The last step here
is that because we're
popping the minimum
from our priority
queue, the thing
with the smallest
shortest-path distance,
this has to be less than
or equal to the shortest-path
distance estimate to y.
Because this is the smallest
among all such vertices
in my Q.
But these are the same value.
So everything between
here is the same value.
In particular, the
estimate here is
equal to my true
shortest-path distance,
which is exactly what
we're trying to prove.
OK, so that's why
Dijkstra's correct.
I'm going to spend the last
five minutes on the running
time of Dijkstra.
We set this up so
that we did everything
in terms of these Q operations.
Right so we have
these Q operations,
we have three of them.
I'm going to say if I
have a build operation,
let's say it takes
B time; to lead min,
I'm going to say it takes M
time; and this decreased key,
I'm going to say
it takes D time.
So what is the running
time of Dijkstra?
If I take a look at that
algorithm over there--
well I guess let's switch
these back up again.
OK, so what does this do?
We build once.
Then we delete the minimum
from the Q how many times?
v times.
We remove every
vertex from our Q.
Then for every
possible edge, we may
need to relax and decrease
the key in our queue
once for every outgoing edge.
So the running time is B plus
V times M plus E times D. OK.
So how could we implement
this priority queue?
Well, if we use the stupidest
priority queue in the world,
here's a list of
different implementations
we could have for
our priority queues.
And when I say priority queue,
I mean this priority queue.
We're already implementing
the changeable priority queue
by linking it with a
dictionary that's efficient
If I just use an array, I can
find the min in linear time,
sure.
And I don't have to update
that array in any way.
I mean, I can just
keep the distances
in my direct access array.
I don't have to store a
separate data structure.
I just store the distances
in my direct access array D,
and so I can find
it in constant time
and I can update the
values stored there.
And then whenever
I want the minimum,
I can just loop through
the whole thing.
So that gives me a
really fast decrease key,
but slow delete min.
But if we take a look at
the running time bound here,
we get something, if
we replace n with v,
we get a quadratic
time algorithm
in the number of vertices,
which for a dense graph,
this is in linear time.
That's actually pretty good.
Dense meaning that I have
at least a quadratic number
of vertices.
So that's actually
really good, and it's
the stupidest possible
data structure
we could use for
this priority queue.
Now we can do a little better,
actually, for not dense--
I mean, for sparse graphs
where the number of edges
is at most v, then this is
pretty bad, it's quadratic.
We want to do something
a little better.
Now if we're sparse,
a binary heap
can delete min in
logarithmic time,
but it can actually, if I know
where I am in the heap and I
decrease the key and
I'm in a min heap,
I can just swap with
my parent upwards
in the tree in log n time
and rebalance the-- refix
the binary heap property.
And so I can do that
in logarithmic time.
And if I do that and I
put it into this formula,
I actually get n--
or V plus V times log
V plus E times log V.
And so that's going to give me
E log V if I'm assuming that I'm
first pruning out all of the
things not connected to me,
then E asymptotically
upper bounds V,
and I get this E log V running
time, which is pretty good.
That's just an extra
log factor on linear.
Now there's an even better--
well, better is hard to say.
Really, there's a
different data structure
that achieves both bounds
for sparse and dense graphs
and everything in between.
It gives us an E plus V
log V running time bound.
This data structure is
called the Fibonacci heap.
We're not going to
talk about it in 6.006.
They talk about it-- and you
can look at chapter 19 in CLRS
or you can look at--
I think they talk
about it in 6.854
if you're interested in
learning about Fibonacci heaps.
But these are almost never--
I mean, they get good
theoretical bounds.
So what you want to say
is, whenever we give you
a theory problem where you
might want to use Dijkstra,
you want to use this
theoretical running time bound
for your problem E plus
V log V. But if you
happen to know that your graph
is sparse or dense, just using
an array or a heap is
going to get you just as
good of a running time.
Very close to linear.
And so in practice, most people,
when they are implementing
a graph search
algorithm, they know
if their graph is
sparse or dense,
and so they never bother
implementing a Fibonacci heap,
which is a little complicated.
So they're usually either in
one of these first two cases
where V squared is linear
when your graph is dense,
or we're very close to linear,
E times log V, which is V log
V if your graph is sparse.
So that's the running
time of Dijkstra.
So so far, we've gotten
all of these nice bounds.
Some special cases where we're--
I mean, special cases
where we're linear.
Dijkstra where we're
close to linear.
And Bellman-Ford, if we throw
our hands up in the air,
there might be negative
cycles in our graph,
we gotta spend that
quadratic running time bound.
Now there are faster
algorithms, but this
is the fastest we're going
to teach you in this class.
Now and in the
next lecture we're
going to be talking about
all pair shortest paths,
and we'll pick it up next time.